it doesn't matter how far you might rise
at some point
you are bound to stumble if you want to
learn physics feynman wrote the book
uh just read the damn book it's all
there
if it is even one percent why are we
running this experiment
wanna be happy build a life not just a
[Music]
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too
you have michael jordan level genius at
something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn the seven lessons from
oprah winfrey
bill gates and other billionaire
entrepreneurs
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with lesson
number one learn from every mistake with
oprah winfrey
it doesn't matter how far you might rise
at some point
you are bound to stumble because if
you're constantly doing
what we do raising the bar
if you're constantly pushing yourself
higher higher
the law of averages not to mention the
myth of icarus
uh predicts that you will at some point
fall and when you do i want you to know
this remember this
there is no such thing as failure
failure is just
life trying to move us in another
direction now
when you're down there in a hole it
looks like failure
so this past year i had to spoon feed
those words to myself
and when you're down in the hole when
that moment comes it's really okay to
feel
bad for a little while give yourself
time to mourn what you think you may
have lost
but then here's the key learn
from every mistake because every
experience encounter and particularly
your mistakes
are there to cheat you and force you
into being more of who you are lesson
number two find a way to learn with bill
gates
if you want to learn computer science
just you know knuth
wrote the book buy it okay uh you know
read it and do the problems for if you
really think you know this thing
if you want to learn physics feynman
wrote the book uh
just read the damn book it's all there
so that
when we put stuff online it we don't
have anything in online physics that's
any better than feynman's book
honest honestly now it's a little easier
to learn
uh you know the guy makes jokes every 20
minutes or at least tries to
uh and he does more demos and things so
learning is a weird social phenomena
and so you know our foundation our big
problem is that
the group that does the worst with
online learning are low-income
students because their notion of why am
i learning
their sense of self-confidence the
ability to figure out oh i just got
stuck
because you know two minuses cancel out
and i i never
saw that notation before they just hit
dead ends
all the time that if you're sitting in
your dorm at stanford you know somebody
walks down and
helps you get through it lesson number
three have a healthy skepticism with
elon musk
i believe in the scientific method and
one should be one should have a healthy
skepticism of things in general and
you know as if first things from a
scientific standpoint you always look at
things probabilistically not
definitively
and so i think a lot a lot of times if
somebody's a skeptic in the science
community what they're really saying is
that they're not sure that it's 100
certain
that that this is the case but that's
that's that's not the point the point is
um that is is is to look at it from the
other side
what do you think the percentage chance
is of this being
catastrophic for some meaningful
percentage of the earth's population
um is it greater than one percent is it
even one percent
um if it is even one percent why are we
running this experiment
also if you want to build more
confidence the sign says it can take up
to 254 days
of consecutive action to successfully
build
a habit so i've created a free program
for you where every day
for 254 days i will send you an
unlisted video to your email absolutely
free to help you build your confidence
the link to join is in the description
below you really have to believe the
internet's going to be mainstream
before we were able to get the roadster
out then they'd say
well you couldn't possibly make that car
work if everything has to work in two to
three years
then that limits what you can do lesson
number four spend your time
wisely with jeff bezos we don't meet
with our biggest investors
we meet with investors who have low
portfolio turns
so uh you know
investors that have you know many
investors many investment funds
have very high portfolio terms they turn
their portfolio multiple times per year
they're not really investors they're
traders there's nothing wrong with that
it's just a different thing
but where are you going to spend your
time your energy is one of the most
important decisions you get to make in
life we all have a limited amount of
time
where you spend it and how you spend it
is is
just an incredibly levered way to think
about the world and
so if you're going to spend time you
know
uh explaining the stock
and or the company really we don't
really explain the stock we explain the
company
to people you should do it to people who
are long-term investors
rather than traders that's our point of
view lesson number five
avoid credit cards with warren buffett
as a general matters of one piece of
specific finance
financial advice i would say you know
avoid credit cards
just forget about them uh we're in
various businesses that issue credit
cards the american public loves credit
cards but if you start revolving debt on
credit cards you're going to be paying
18 or 20 percent and you can't make
progress in your financial life going
around borrowing money at 18 or 20
percent
you can make a lot of money by lending
it out at 18 or 20
over time you know if you can find
anybody that's good that
will borrow from you but you don't want
to be on the side of the equation
that's always behind in life uh
you know i was lucky i'd saved about ten
thousand dollars by the time i got out
of school that ten thousand dollars was
really worth millions i might have
earned later on because after you get a
family and everything the
expenses roll in but but those were my
tools to work with but it was only
because i was ahead of the game
if you're behind the game by ten
thousand dollars at some point and
paying eighteen or twenty percent
interest on it you will never you know
you'll never get out of it so
the trick i've got a partner that says
all i want to know is where i'm going to
die so i'll never go there
you know and and that's true in
financial matters as well you want to
figure out where you don't want to be
ahead of time and avoid that and i get
about a dozen letters a day
from people who are having terrible
problems and there are two reasons why
they have terrible problems
one is a number of them have had health
problems of some sort i mean they have
really been hit by some or somebody in
their family has been hit by some kind
of catastrophic
illness and that is a you know it's a
terrible thing to happen to any family
and they get in they run up bills they
can't pay and
and really only society can solve that
one uh
uh in terms of protecting people against
that that's just plain bad luck
but the other one is from people who run
up credit card debt
and uh they're facing bankruptcy or
they've been through bankruptcy once
before
and they owe a whole bunch of money and
they can't they can't even pay the
interest let alone pay any principal
and half of my letters come from people
like that and that that that problem is
avoidable
catastrophic illness is not but but uh
credit card debt is something you bring
on yourself and
it's way better it's way easier to stay
out of trouble
than to get out of trouble financially
and and i will guarantee you if you run
a big credit card that
you will be in trouble uh probably the
rest of your life
in terms of uh your financial situation
on the other hand if you get ahead of
the game
uh even on a very modest scale so that
money is coming in from investing and
you're you're
you people owe you money or equities owe
you ownership
uh you'll be way out of the game
compared to paying it uh
being always being paying your creditors
every month
so my advice to you is if you can't pay
for it
don't buy it lesson number six think
about the future with jack ma
with such a great infrastructure of the
internet you have
with the so many people in the world
today know about the internet
they're today but more than 1.7 billion
people
are already online but that time
total china less than like 500 people
using internet
it's difficult but as i said just
in the other room everybody when you
have a dream
you have to dream globally or you have
to win locally
you have to survive today but you also
have to think about the future
if you do not think about the future if
you do not have a vision for 10 years
later what will you be
you will never have a great people
follow you and join your company
but if you cannot survive
you go nowhere and lesson number seven
the last one before a very special bonus
clip
is don't look for the formula with mark
cuban
do you think there's a proven formula
that if
a brand rookie guy he's got a lot of
ambitious gone out of this but not a lot
of knowledge and how to
do you think if he follows a formula
he's guaranteed to make it as an
entrepreneur no no
okay so you don't believe there's a
guarantee to make it no because who
knows who you're going to be competing
with
so if you put two two people both
following the same formula both in the
same industry
right which one wins you know maybe they
both can win and both be successful but
you know so i don't i don't think
there's a default default template for
success
but i think there's things that you can
do to put yourself in the best position
to succeed you know so i talk about
stuff in the book
you know i talk about the one thing in
business you can control his effort
you know um going out there and sales
curing all
you know so i i think you know and i
agree with your point that
there are things that if you do them you
put yourself in the best position to
succeed
but you know if you just walk into a
buzz you know
a buzzsaw and somebody else is doing
them a little bit better you know what
happens
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and what is your plan of action that
you're going to execute this week
to make some immediate momentum happen
when you just get motivated
and watch a video you have a 35 chance
of following through that's what the
science says but when you write down
what time what day what place you're
actually going to execute when you
create the plan
you have a 91 chance of following
through
and i want that for you and when you
commit to people publicly
you increase your chances even more of
actually doing it
so i want to know what your single
biggest takeaway from this video was
and your specific plan of action
to actually get the result you're after
let me know put it down the comments
below
because i want to celebrate you
what is your decision making process or
thinking when it comes to investing your
time
your money your energy sure uh it's very
important because time is the most
valuable thing you have
is one make sure where you're putting
your time and energy
is something you want to do not just
because you're exploring with people you
don't like or a business you don't like
or a situation don't like
time is so valuable try and speak if
you're speaking to people or a situation
to people you feel there's hope for that
you can do something with
to do something great not just make
money
whenever you go into business or in a
relationship with someone
just to make money then it means you've
already decided to take a portion of
your time to make these papers that are
backed up by nothing but will buy
stuff call it a possession
we have all these great possessions well
if you have these great possessions
could you give them away if you had any
possession you could give it away
hey great it was a possession and you
moved on if you can't give that
possession away to somebody
just give it away then it possesses you
[Music]
if you want to change your life in the
next 30 days for free check out my
training right here below or if you want
seven more awesome lessons from
billionaires check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy
them
continue to believe and i'll see you
[Music]
there